I want I want to get an idea of the
ladies when what stepping into your
feminine
means because it's being it's it's being
posited almost in a way that it's
something that you have to do actively
or you're not just generally feminine
and that you have to choose to be
feminine I'm looking for a little more
clarity on that what you all mean by
stepping into your
femininity um I guess I can start
because I was saying feminine but I
don't think it's something we have to
step into necessarily I think that I
mean we all have healing work and Trauma
work and all the stuff that we can do
that lets us be more of ourselves and
more of you know who we are naturally
but I think just I mean we're all women
here so being feminine it just is what
it is I mean we all have the masculine
and feminine within us of course but
yeah I don't think it's something we
necessarily have to try to do I mean in
in the perspective of being in
relationships in theast past like I've
had boyfriends and I think it's just I
mean who I am as a as a woman just
naturally being in the feminine role
that's just how it is you
know yeah only only questions because I
often hear it's it's positive almost
like it's a choice right so I don't
choose to be masculine I'm just Mas yeah
exactly it's not a choice we just are
are yeah I don't know I kind of I
disagree a little bit just in that I do
think there can be an on andof switch in
my experiences and I'm thinking of other
women that I Aspire you know look up to
in my life and because of people in
their Liv they've had to be both roles
they've had to be mother and father
right they like for example if you lose
a you know a parent whatever whatever
they have to be both roles so they had
to snap into their masculine and their
en and their feminine and then the
perfect example is when I can literally
feel it when I'm around someone who
allows me that space to what I call step
into my femininity sometimes it is like
natural like I'm naturally wanting to
take care of them I'm naturally wanting
to nurture and and kind of nest and
those little attributes it is a little
bit natural but then there is also a
level of I have to click where I'm like
oh I can trust this man he is the head
he is someone I can it's really to be
able to have a woman fully be submissive
and I I think it's the most beautiful
thing in the Flippin world if you can if
you deserve that if a man deserves that
because that that means that woman
trusts you so innately in her soul and
then yes then it becomes an active
choice of yes I'm choosing to no matter
what I'm he tells me to walk forward I
can have my blinders on I'm walking
forward because I trust him I don't like
the dominant or submissive thing because
it's like you can be dominant and I can
be submissive in the bedroom but when it
comes to everything else like that's
when it's like okay we're we're we we
are a co- team like we this is our
relationship not just mine not just his
relationship it's our relationship so we
have to you know we really want to make
this work I have to see it on both ends
you know it's it's
never I just don't relationships that
are relationships that are dominated by
women don't work out often I'm not
saying I dominate again like I don't
like using those terms outside the
bedroom but I'm saying like in a
marriage or in a
relationship there should outside the
bedroom there shouldn't be any like use
of the word of dominant or you know
submissive like I want to do this
because I love you that's not being
submissive that's just showing your your
love for them and they should do the
same I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out